pour la première fois de la Cinquième
République
un président nouvellement élu ne
parvient pas à réunir une majorité à
l'élection législative qui suit si
l'Assemblée nationale compte 577 sièges
pour obtenir la majorité absolue il faut
289 députés selon les différentes
projections ensemble le parti de la
majorité présidentielle devrait obtenir
entre 255 et 295 sièges en cas de
majorité relative il faudra aller
chercher des alliances politiques pour
mener à bien les réformes faudra
négocier bien davantage avec les autres
forces à l'Assemblée nationale que ce
soit la droite ou certaines forces de
gauche soit pour obtenir un minima
qu'elle s'abstiennent sur les textes
soit idéalement qu'elle se rallie
ponctuellement texte par textes en cas
de majorité relative le parti
présidentiel devra aussi compter sur ses
alliés au sein d'ensemble pour appliquer
son programme mais la rivalité supposée
entrée manuel Macron et Édouard
qui ne cache pas ses ambitions pour 2027
pourrait provoquer des romous on peut
tout à fait imaginer que certaines
composantes de la majorité Horizont bien
sûr avec Édouard Philippe ou même le
modem avec François Bayrou soit un grain
de sable dans la chaussure du parti
majoritaire et du président de la
République puisse empêcher
l'aboutissement de certaines réformes
enfin en cas de difficulté le
gouvernement pourrait recourir à
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution il
permet l'adoption d'une loi sans vote
mais son usage est limité hors texte
budgétaire cette procédure ne peut être
utilisée que sur un seul projet de loi
au cours d'une même session
parlementaire
quelle majorité éventuelle pour Emmanuel
Macron Jean-Luc Mélenchon peut-il
finalement réussir son son pari voilà
les thèmes que l'on va aborder notamment
tout de suite dans ce débat avec leur
salvats bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice générale de cantar public
France j'accueille également Benjamin
Morel bonsoir bonsoir Benjamin maître de
conférence en droit public à
l'Université Paris de Panthéon Assas
Jean-Sébastien Ferjou bonsoir bien sûr
Jean-Sébastien vous êtes le fondateur et
le directeur
d'Atlantico et Mathieu croissanto est
resté à mes côtés comme de juste on va
pour lancer ce débat regardez une l'une
des projections de l'institut
Ipsos sopra Steria enfin avec son
partenaire sopra Steria projection en
siège à l'Assemblée la nupesse entre 150
et 190 divers gauche 15 25 ensemble la
coalition présidentielle entre 255 et
295 le parti elle est ses alliée
notamment l'idée 50 à 80 sièges et le
rassemblement national entre 20 et 45
l'oral je commence avec vous parce que
je sais que ça ça vous plaît pas
forcément ces projections en siège
pourquoi
vous attaquez fort
j'avoue ça m'agace un peu parce que on
est au lendemain du premier tour des
élections législatives il y a des
résultats du premier tour de ces
élections législatives il y a une
campagne de second tour avec des
stratégies
électorales politiques et puis des
stratégies aussi des citoyens des
électeurs qui sont complètement
différents entre le premier et le second
tour donc je trouve ça très
au-delà je veux dire au-delà du côté un
peu hasardeux vous voyez parce que c'est
vraiment faire une projection après
quelque chose qui n'a qui ne sait pas
encore passé c'est aussi vis-à-vis des
citoyens leur voler un petit peu cette
semaine de campagne de seconde voilà
c'est pour ça que je les regarde avec un
faible intérêt j'avoue voilà je regarde
ce que ça donne mais je trouve que c'est
en tout cas c'est pas conforme à ce que
demande aussi les citoyens aujourd'hui
qu'on les écoute comprennent le temps de
les écouter et chaque chose en son temps
quelque part c'est le premier tour
des élections donc parlons de ce premier
tour avant même de se projeter sur la
projection je vais vous faire un aveu je
respecte beaucoup le travail de la
rédaction de TF1 c'est l'une de mes
anciennes maisons mais hier soir à 20h
quand j'ai vu que la première
proposition finalement que faisait la
rédaction au téléspectateurs c'était
justement cette projection du second
tour Benjamin Morel moi ça m'a un peu
comme vous je me suis dit est-ce qu'on
met pas un peu la charrue avant avant
les bœufs oui je suis assez d'accord
pour deux raisons alors en réalité c'est
quand même beaucoup plus fiable que ce
que l'on avait avant le premier tour ou
pour le coup vous aviez pas encore les
schémas des différents seconds tours
dans chaque circo donc c'était très très
hasardeuse là ça se base au moins sur de
vrai second tour on peut penser qu'il y
a une fiabilité un peu plus grande mais
en réalité relativement faible et je
suis assez d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit parce que cette campagne entre deux
tours elle a un impact souvenez-vous de
la gave de bord loin 2016 qui fait
perdre 50 sièges à LR souvenez-vous même
des projections d'entre de Tours d'il y
a 5 ans dans lesquels on prévoyait 400 à
440 députés pour la République en marche
et où au bout du compte il y en a eu
beaucoup moins tout bêtement parce
qu'une campagne de second tour et bien
ça compte et ça compte au moins autant
qu'une campagne de premier tour parce
que vous avez une restructuration des
électorats et parce que localement vous
avez une offre politique qui tout d'un
coup s'éclaircit puisque on va avoir
quasiment que des duels lors de cette
législative donc ce faisant ces
projections avec tout le respect qu'on
doit à nos amis sondeurs évidemment ne
veulent pas dire grand-chose à ce stade
là et l'accompagne au second tour va
avoir un impact respectons-la je vous
rejoins et puis très très clair si nos
amis sont d'heures font ces projections
c'est parce que on est très content de
les avoir et de pouvoir les commenter
voilà Jean-Sébastien faire joujou
qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé peut-être
une analyse un peu général de la des
résultats et de la et de la soirée
d'hier
l'abstention il a fait ça c'est le
premier chiffre qui vous vient c'est on
en a pas parlé dans le premier débat
j'avais prévu et ben on peut démarrer
là-dessus si vous souhaitez l'abstention
parce que en réalité on parle de
recomposition de la vie politique mais
on est dans la décomposition qui
continue finalement et on voit bien que
le premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas permis de restructurer la vie
politique contrairement aux apparences
parce que là les blocs ils sont
finalement très superficiels c'est plus
du vote par défaut que ça n'est de
l'adhésion moi je crois pas tellement
d'ailleurs la théorie des blocs
sociologiques et celles de Jérôme
Sainte-Marie enfin plus exactement elle
est très explicative effectivement on
voit bien que la catégorie sociale à
laquelle on appartient ou le niveau
diplôme des revenus est un assez bon
prédicteur du vote en revanche ça n'est
que par défaut c'est-à-dire que les gens
qui ont quelque chose à perdre votre
faut le statu quo le statut quo c'est
qui c'est Emmanuel Macron ceux qui n'ont
rien à perdre peuvent se permettre des
votes ou des recherches d'alternatives
plus radicales mais ça n'est pas
paradisions fondamentalement à ce que
sont ces alternatives ou à ce
qu'incarnent en soi le statu quo
maintenant moi il y a autre chose qui
m'a frappé hier soir pour le coup dans
les là ça n'est pas du sondage en
projection mais c'était vous savez les
sondages jour de vote on demande aux
gens qu'est-ce qui a motivé leur
intention de vote et notamment quand se
sont-ils décidés il y a 22% des Français
qui se sont décidés pendant le week-end
il n'y en avait que 30 ou 31 si je me
souviens bien qu'il savait depuis le
départ pour qu'ils allaient voter ce
cirque il n'y a que 30% moins du tiers
des Français qui sont fixés
politiquement donc j'en reviens à
l'abstention des compositions moins du
tiers des Français qui sont fixés
politiquement on voit bien qu'on est
toujours dans une phase de décomposition
et que rien n'a été reconstruit Benjamin
l'opération que cette abstention a été
historique
elle est un peu singulière par rapport
aux abstentions qu'on avait connues lors
des dernières législatives post-quinat
ou en réalité on avait un phénomène de
participation différentielle assez
classique qu'on avait une partie de
lectorat de position qui n'allait pas
voter parce qu'il jugeait qu'il avait
perdu et donc c'était plus le symbole
d'une femme enfin le symptôme d'une
forme de fatalisme qu'une forme de
dépolitisation là cette abstention qui
est à peu près dans les mêmes eaux que
celle de 2017 elle est quand même un peu
différente ou comme entier tout à
l'heure lors du précédent plateau le
taux de participation des électeurs RN
les électeurs RN qui d'habitude se
démobilisent là ce sont pas si mal
mobilisés Jean-Luc Mélenchon a réussi à
mobiliser une partie de l'électorale
gauche etc donc on n'a pas directement
ce phénomène de participation
différentielle qui a joué à plein
électorat du président de la République
c'est un peu démobilisé également en
réalité on a plutôt un phénomène de
désintérêt ce qui est probablement plus
grave pour cette élection et ce qui
rejoint en réalité les élections
précédentes ce qui le rend d'autant plus
grave on n'a pas eu réellement
d'élections municipales parce qu'il y
avait eu réforme des retraites et
ensuite covid on n'a pas eu de campagne
des départementales et régionales parce
que et bien on avait une opinion qui
était focalisée sur la covid les
présidentielles et législatives sont
passées sous le saut de l'Ukraine on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui et bien vous
avez un phénomène de dépolitisation du
lectorat qui est profond et qui implique
une crise de la représentation avec une
crise de la représentativité le
sentiment que il n'y aurait pas
réellement d'offres adéquat or quand
vous regardez
l'éventail des propositions
présidentielles et aux législatives vous
avez une offre qui est pléthorique alors
on est quand même l'un des seuls pays au
présidentiel vous avez trois tendances
de trots ou de ça dépend parfois vous
avez le parti de travailleur parfois pas
donc il y a malgré tout une offre mais
cette offre n'est pas lisible n'est pas
vue n'est pas perçue et de l'autre côté
vous avez le sentiment d'une impotence
du politique qui fait que voter certes
mais à quoi bon et là pour le coup on
rentre dans une crise structurelle
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
Jean-Sébastien faire jouer est-ce qu'il
y a une offre ou est-ce que cette offre
elle est finalement pas assez travaillée
pas assez novatrice pas assez en phase
avec avec les l'époque
manifestement n'est pas assez travaillé
regarder les chiffres de participation
mais je crois que oui on est dans une
phase et de décomposition et des
politisations et la stratégie d'Emmanuel
Macron a peut-être été il n'est pas il
n'a pas créé cette des politisations
mais il a probablement accentuer on ne
cherchant pas à reconstruire des
clivages politiques et puis finalement
contrairement à 2017 où il avait
probablement plus de clarté dans la
ligne qui souhaitait incarner là si
quelqu'un a compris exactement ce qui
était la ligne de Monsieur Macron en
matière de sécurité en matière
d'éducation en matière de santé il
faudrait qu'il explique et donc il joue
consciemment sur la dépolitisation
finalement en misant sur le dernier
réflexe c'est-à-dire celui du vote utile
c'est qu'est-ce qui nous dit en gros ne
votez pas pour les autres parce qu'ils
sont incompétents et ou dangereux mais
ça c'est pas un critère politique le
incompétent et ou dangereux on peut être
incompétent et intéressant politiquement
ou intéressant politiquement et
compétent enfin bref vous avez compris
donc il y a cette des politisations là
mais je crois en revanche que
l'abstention elle est pour partie
politique c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
gens qui se désintéressent véritablement
qui ne croient plus à la politique ça
c'est ça c'est évident et qu'il y a des
gens qui eux délibérément choisissent de
s'abstenir parce qu'il me voit plus
d'autres moyens pour essayer d'attirer
d'attirer l'attention du système une
réaction celle de la première ministre
Elisabeth borne elle s'est adressée à
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas voté hier
on l'écoute
on a quelques dizaines de
circonscriptions dans lequel on a un
duel entre RN et Nupe
notre position c'est aucune voie pour le
Front national ensuite quand on a des
candidats Nupe très clairement si on a
affaire un candidat qui ne respecte pas
les valeurs républicaines qui insultent
nos policiers qui demandent de ne plus
soutenir l'Ukraine qui veut sortir de
l'Europe nous n'applons pas à voter pour
lui vous savez quoi ça arrive cette
intervention des événements on l'avait
prévu un peu plus tard elle est très
intéressante on y reviendra on l'écoute
sur l'abstention c'est parti
Elisabeth borne
ou pas
3 2 1 0
aujourd'hui plus d'un Français sur deux
ne s'est pas rendu aux urnes et cela
personne ne peut s'y résoudre notre
premier devoir collectif c'est de faire
reculer l'abstention nous continuerons
d'Yeu vrai en réformant nos institutions
et en modernisant le dialogue avec toute
la société à toutes celles et ceux qui
se sont abstenus je veux dire ce soir de
croire dans la force de leur vote et de
faire entendre leur voix dimanche
prochain leur Salvin on parle de
l'abstention dans ce premier chapitre
dans le débat est-ce que vous pouvez on
peut croire à une mobilisation pour le
second tour ou est-ce que c'est
totalement illusoire
c'est possible effectivement qu'il y ait
une mobilisation d'un camp ou de l'autre
justement on parlait de cette campagne
de second tour c'est tout l'enjeu des
forces des différentes forces en
présence et notamment des trois
principales forces en présence d'essayer
de remobiliser leur camp parce que 50%
de la population qui s'est absenue ça
fait une réserves de voix énorme et
notamment à gauche en fait mais est-ce
que c'est pas en cru ou en contre que
cette mobilisation peut se faire ça
rejoint un peu ce que disait
Jean-Sébastien tout à l'heure c'est dire
que des électeurs de gauche qui vont se
mobiliser pour empêcher
éventuellement une victoire du
rassemblement national et donc voter
pour un candidat ensemble et puis on
peut on peut multiplier les exemples
alors il y a effectivement ce ce cette
dynamique mais il peut aussi y avoir
l'inverse c'est-à-dire des des électeurs
qui sont portés par l'élan du premier
tour de la gauche ou du rassemblement
national aussi c'est à dire
effectivement personne ne pensait que le
rassemblement national allait se
maintenir à un niveau aussi important
donc il y a aussi ce phénomène là qui
veut dire tient finalement c'est pas si
mal et on peut continuer et je pense
aussi malgré tout qu'il y a un point
qu'on arrivera pas à résorber pendant
cette campagne de second tour c'est le
sens de ces élections législatives c'est
à dire qu'au-delà de la dépolitisation
et de l'éloignement des citoyens
français à l'égard de leur politique
leurs hommes et femmes politiques il y a
aussi cette question du sens de ces
élections législatives aujourd'hui les
Français quand on les interroge ils ne
savent pas à quoi servent ces élections
législatives à quoi sert l'Assemblée
nationale
ils ne connaissent pas le poids réel de
l'Assemblée nationale il en a aucune
idée donc c'est quand même difficile
aussi même s'il y a un élan une
dynamique etc c'est difficile de
mobiliser des gens sur quelque chose qui
ne comprennent pas
Isabelle borne tenir un discours qui est
honorable mais que tiennent tout les
premiers ministres en exercice qui
disent qu'il faut entendre le message
des abstentionnistes et se désoler les
Français ils sont pas en rapport à la
politique qui s'est dégradé de façon
délirante vraiment ils sont passés d'une
forme de doute à une forme de dépit de
la déception à des désespoir à dû
dégagisme du désintérêt et maintenant
c'est une forme de détachement c'est ce
que disait d'ailleurs je sais pas si
j'ai l'impression que ça ne les concerne
plus parce que on ne les entend plus et
le problème c'est que toutes les
alternatives qu'on a à cette crise de
leur présentation
démocratique il y a tout ce qu'on
attendait de démocratie plus ou moins
participatif plus ou moins différentes
n'a pas fonctionné n'a pas non plus
produit les résultats le ce quinquennat
sous le Quinquin qui est la précédent
pardon il y a eu cette initiative de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
a été très critiquée par les
participants eux-mêmes par les
politiques qui voulaient pas qu'on
vienne sur leur plate-bande on n'a pas
tellement d'alternative au-delà d'une
réforme institutionnelle que tout le
monde appelle de ses vœux mais que
personne ne fait jamais c'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'il faut introduire la
proportionnelle est-ce qu'il faut
expliquer aux gens ce qui à quoi sert un
député qui fabrique la loi comment
pourquoi l'impression qu'on parle de
très très loin quand même non mais tout
à fait mais peut-être la première chose
fait tout simplement d'utiliser le
Parlement pour ce à quoi il est censé
servir à savoir d'ailleurs c'est pas
fondamentalement écrire la loi la voter
oui mais pas l'écrire on transpose
beaucoup de droits européens donc c'est
pas fondamentalement au Parlement
français que la loi s'écrit en revanche
le Parlement et là pour contrôler
l'action de l'exécutif et cette mission
là qui est absolument essentielle dans
une démocratie cette mission d'équilibre
des pouvoirs elle n'est plus assurée et
c'est pour ça qu'on peut toujours
essayer d'inventer des bidules et des
machins des conseils ou des conférences
citoyennes mais si la culture
démocratique n'est pas là en premier
lieu parce qu'il peut y avoir une
intention parfaitement cynique de la
part d'Emmanuel Macron avec le Conseil
national de la refondation si se dit de
toute façon pour reprendre l'expression
de Marine Le Pen ça va être la ZAD a
raison de la présence de beaucoup de
députés de l'anus c'est d'une pierre
deux coups de dire on va faire un truc
qui sera en amont ou en consultera les
partenaires sociaux et puis des citoyens
tirés au sort et puis ça sera le moyen
de délégitimer et le Sénat qui est tenu
par l'opposition et l'Assemblée
nationale mais oui mais le problème
c'est que quand vous êtes la moyenne des
électeurs ne s'intéresse pas à ce genre
de détail là sauf qu'ils sont bien qu'on
n'est pas regardé pendant le covid il y
a pas eu beaucoup de contrôle de
l'action de l'exécutif sur le Stade de
France on l'a vu le Sénat a fait un peu
son travail le Sénat fait quand même
régulièrement son travail soit avec des
commissions bancaires soit en
l'occurrence c'était les études avec
il a été établi que le professeur
Salomon avait menti devant la commission
au parlementaire du Sénat il est
toujours le directeur général de la
santé j'ai à partir du moment où il y a
pas de principe de responsabilité dans
les institutions françaises à partir du
moment où il n'y a pas d'équilibre des
pouvoirs on pourrait le décliner sur
beaucoup de choses y compris sur
l'autorité l'indépendance de la justice
la conseillère justice de Monsieur
Macron qui est nommé première présidente
du tribunal de Bastia parce que elle
sait elle-même autant inscrite dans la
liste où elle était dernière enfin il y
a beaucoup de choses qu'on pourrait dire
mais ça c'est un défaut de culture
démocratique et pas spécifique à
Monsieur Macron c'est finalement
l'ensemble de la classe politique
française qui s'est enfin qui a fini par
qui s'est résigné à ça parce que le
contrôle du Parlement les la
constitutions existent les oppositions
pourraient le faire bien plus qu'elles
ne l'ont fait j'ai un
constitutionnalisme intervenir la force
alors le problème si vous voulez c'est
que le endroit parlementaire on a quand
même minoré le poids des oppositions et
donc à partir de là dès le moment où
vous avez une majorité disciplinée
pléthorique ce qu'est la logique en
réalité et du mode de scrutin et du
télescopage des calendriers et bien vous
avez une majorité qui tient l'Assemblée
nationale qui incarne le Palais Bourbon
et comme le Sénat un pouvoir de contrôle
mais pouvoir comme relativement limité
parce que vous pouvez pas renverser le
gouvernement et bien vous avez une sorte
d'exécutif qui se sont poussés des ailes
et qui n'a plus réellement à rendre de
compte au Parlement or je rejoins ce qui
a été dit les électeurs vont voter quand
ils pensent qu'il y a un enjeu or
regardez les dernières élections
américaines ça c'est intéressant les
Américains sont très abstentionnistes
mais là il y avait un enjeu il y avait
Donald Trump vous votez pour Donald
Trump ou contre Donald Trump mais ça
paraît quand même comme engageant un peu
l'avenir des États-Unis donc les
Américains vont voter quand vous pensez
que les élections légatives ne vont rien
changer parce que le Parlement n'a pas
de pouvoir ce qui est très faux en droit
le président de la République n'a que
des pouvoirs d'exception le vrai pouvoir
il est au gouvernement responsable
devant le Parlement mais le fait que ça
ne fonctionne pas comme ça pourquoi
parce que vous avez de majorité
pléthorique je parle pas que de celle
présente et des prêts de mais également
des précédentes qui est aux ordres et
qui répond aux ordres de l'Elysée donc
des moments vous obtenez l'Élysée vous
tenez le palais Bourbons vous tenez
matinignon quel est l'enjeu d'aller
voter pour les législatives si demain
vous changez de système que vous avez
par exemple une proportionnelle des
accords de coalition et où tout d'un
coup et bien il y a un enjeu à ces
élections où ça peut changer justement
la politique qui est menée dans le pays
forcément vous avez une repolitisation
et si vous avez une repolitisation bah
pour beaucoup de Français il y a une
raison d'aller voter alors je voudrais
qu'on ouvre maintenant le chapitre
consacré c'est l'interview l'extralité à
bedboard qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure
on va pas la réécouter mais ces
hésitations auxquelles on a tous assisté
Jean-Sébastien falou hier soir au sein
de
la majorité présidentielle Isabelle
borne d'autres ministres sur les
consignes de vote en cas de duel entre
le rassemblement national et la nuque
comment vous vous avez réagi hier soir
en insistant à ce à cette valse
hésitation
c'est assez confondant pour deux types
de raisons d'une part que la majorité
actuelle en tout cas sortante n'est pas
anticipée que la configuration allait se
poser c'est pas très difficile à
consommer quelques circonscriptions et
le deuxième point est par ailleurs la
solution qui a finalement été abordée en
disant pas une voix à l'extrême droite
pourquoi pas mais finalement la nuse ça
paraît relativement acceptable et ça à
mes yeux c'est une forme de mépris
social de racisme social parce que je
vois pas particulièrement en quoi le
rassemblement national on peut ne pas du
tout partager ni les valeurs ni le
programme ni les intentions du
rassemblement national mais je ne crois
pas que le rassemblement national soit
un danger pour les institutions qu'il se
projette dans autre chose que les
institutions républicaines et au-delà de
ça quel est le sens de permettre à un
parti de se présenter si on considère
que il est un danger pour la démocratie
et finalement vis-à-vis la nuque de ne
pas de faire semblant de passer en
rendre compte mais pourquoi parce que
qui sont les électeurs de la nuque sont
pas les contrairement c'est pas le
peuple quoi que ça veuille dire
d'ailleurs ce sont les quatre chutes des
grandes villes où est-ce que la nuque
s'est élue elle est élu dans le centre
de Paris de Bordeaux de Strasbourg elle
est élu fin ce sont les bourgeois et les
enfants de bourgeois alors oui pas des
arrondissements les plus bourgeois mais
c'est une sociologie qui ne correspond
pas exactement à ce qu'on a au discours
qu'on en tient sur les plateaux et donc
il y a une espèce comme je disais de
méprises sociales parce que d'un côté il
y en a ils ont eux ils ont le droit
d'être antisémites ou de flirter avec
l'antisémitisme ils ont droit de dire
ouvertement que le troisième tour ce
sera dans la rue ce qui est quand même
un appel à l'insurrection enfin en tout
cas moi à mes yeux ou à mes oreilles
c'est un appel à l'insurrection je
n'entends rien de tel chez le
rassemblement national on peut discuter
de la compétence de Marine Le Pen on
peut discuter encore une fois des
valeurs du rassemblement national je ne
les défends pas en soi je vous dis juste
que ce deux points de mesure il est très
révélateur de la démocratie censitaire
finalement dans laquelle on s'est
installé et le macronisme n'est jamais
qu'un produit pour élite fatiguer la
démocratie intéressante analyse je suis
pas sûr que tout le monde soit d'accord
Mathieu
pour une autre raison c'est à dire que
on peut être cours ou contre le Front
républicain Jean-Sébastien il est contre
certains peuvent être pour mais on peut
pas mais on peut pas tous les gens qui
sont censés on ne peut pas être pour
quand ça vous arrange et contre quand ça
vous dérange or c'est exactement ce
qu'il y a de la sentiment qui a donné ce
pouvoir c'est-à-dire à draguer
ouvertement courtisé les électeurs
insoumis pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite au nom du Front républicain
Emmanuel Macron dit mais plus personne
n'en parle les médias font pas leur
boulot etc etc et puis un mois et demi
plus tard quand la menace ne vient plus
d'extrême droite mais de la nupes ou de
la Nupe là dire Ah bah non il y a plus
de front républicains qui tiennent on
voit les extrêmes de dans chaque camp
c'est pas possible ça manque de
cohérence et c'est pas ça manque de
colonne vertébrale mais ça manque de
cohérence mais ça témoigne en réalité
d'une position qui est à la fois
extrêmement avantageuse et en même temps
extrêmement compliqué de aujourd'hui on
sent parce que avec le mode de scrutin
qui est neutre ensemble un avantage
structurel s'il se retrouve au
présidentiel législatif contre le
rassemblement national il varier sur un
report des votes de gauche s'il se
retrouve face à la dupesse il peut
parier sur un report de voix de la
droite donc cette position structurelle
arrange ensemble cette position
structurelle fait que aujourd'hui même
si la nuit Pesse est ensemble sont dans
un mouchoir de poche il est assez
probable pour ne pas dire certains que
au bout du compte ensemble est beaucoup
plus de députés que la nuit pèse le
désavantage d'une telle position c'est
que ça vous oblige à ne pas réellement
avoir de logiciel politique il faut être
capable de jouer sur le castor de droite
sur le castor de gauche de dire un jour
j'ai des valeurs communes avec le
rassemblement national parce que malgré
tout la nuit Pesse est horrible le
lendemain dire non mais la nuit pêche en
réalité on a des valeurs communes
souvenez-vous Richard Ferrand qui
aujourd'hui explique l'inverse parce que
le rassemblement national et le diable
donc cette position centrale vous oblige
à ne pas avoir de logiciels politiques
ça vous donne une majorité quoi qu'il
arrive mais je rejoins ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure c'est fondamentalement
délétères pour la démocratie
quand on regarde justement sur
l'impossibilité politique dans laquelle
et la notamment à cause de son mode de
scrutin si nous avions un scrutin à la
Britannique une inominale majoritaire au
premier tour c'est à dire que les
élections pour le coup ce serait fini
hier soir donc quand on regarde qui est
arrivé en tête c'est celui qui arrive en
tête qui remporte le ciel il y aurait
quoi il y aurait 204 députés ensemble il
y aurait 194 députés de la nuit il y
aurait 111 députés du rassemblement
national 52 députés LR et le reste
mais ça veut dire il y a pas de majorité
possible il y en a pas là vous allez me
dire si on était dans un système à la
Britannique les parties ce serait
organisées autrement mais justement
c'est là où la question devient
intéressante et c'est là où je rejoins
ce que disait Benjamin Morel sur la
question du logiciel politique parce que
vu que c'est impossible ensemble
n'aurait pas de moyens d'avoir de
majorité donc il faudrait bien que soit
il décide d'être un parti de gauche on
allant chercher y compris plus à gauche
dans la nuque soit il décide d'être un
parti de droite en allant chercher plus
à droite y compris sur une partie du
rassemblement national et peut-être que
là ça forcerait justement des logiciels
politiques ne soient pas que des
logiciels finalement sur votre reposant
sur le vote utile parce que comme je
vous le disais
c'est pas Emmanuel Macron soit ou que il
est une majorité ou non le sujet c'est
que c'est un vote qui est devenu
censitaire parce que selon votre
sociologie vous êtes avantagé ou non par
le mode de scrutin et ça c'est
profondément gênant je vous parle pas
selon vos opinions politiques parce que
ça il arrive qu'on soit dans la majorité
dans la dans la minorité mais selon
votre origine sociologique vous êtes ou
non interdit de représentation et ça
c'est profondément toxique alors ça va
sur cette
absence non parce qu'il y a finalement
une consigne de vote mais c'est c'est
hésitations autour des consignes de vote
autour de ces c'est une soixantaine
c'est le choix de mémoire 61 alors oui
je suis plus j'ai vu j'ai vu 59 j'ai vu
61 bref on va dire autour de 60 duels
entre le rassemblement national et la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale il y a il y a peut-être une
explication qui se trouve tout
simplement dans
l'hétérogénéité de la nuque
dans quel nu pour enfin de quelle gauche
on parle quoi de qui parle-t-on
c'est un véritable ovni moi je pense la
en soit elle a quelques semaines
d'existence et on connaît pas exactement
quel est le programme c'est surtout une
union une coalition clairement parce que
c'est difficile aussi d'avoir un
discours commun et unitaire et homogène
pour l'ensemble des circonscriptions
concernées et c'est vrai que c'est pour
ça que le cas par cas il me semble que
c'est
en même temps
avec le rassemblement national je vous
assure qu'on ferait pas la distinction
entre s'agissait-il de quelqu'un qui
venait à l'origine de l'UDF ou quelqu'un
qui était vraiment rassemblement
national on dirait le Front républicain
est valable pour tous les gens qui ont
fait alliance ensemble voilà la seule
chose que je voulais rajouter aussi
c'est que aujourd'hui ça montre encore
un décalage entre l'opinion des Français
et les voix qui s'expriment en politique
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui dans
l'opinion des Français le RN ne
représente pas un danger les idées du RN
sont de plus en plus en accord avec ce
que pense la population française et
donc en faisant ce genre de et en ce
genre de décision je pense que ça montre
encore un décalage qu'on le veuille ou
non et qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec
l'opinion des Français et sans qu'on
explique vraiment les raisons pour
lesquelles on prend cette décision là et
cette position là effectivement d'un
front républicain uni que d'un côté et
pas d'un autre voilà et encore une fois
la question du sens de ces actions
politiques et là moi je comprends aussi
les citoyens au bout d'un moment de dire
bah moi je comprends plus rien et tout
dernier mot là-dessus parce qu'il nous
reste plein de thèmes pour regarder la
surdité des étiquettes politiques la
deuxième circonscription de la Marne
c'est magnifique cette histoire il y
avait une candidate sortant enfin une
députée sortante de la majorité
présidentielle actuelle qui pensait
qu'elle allait être candidate et puis le
dernier jour assez rendu compte qu'elle
n'était pas réinvesti personne n'avait
songé à prévenir une candidate venue de
LR a été investie pourquoi c'est
l'ancienne circonscription de Madame
Vautrin donc peut-être pour la consoler
de ne pas avoir été nommé à Matignon
cette candidat devenue de LR qui
parvient avait demandé l'investiture de
LR et criminel dans laquelle demander
l'investisseur de LR en disant qu'elle
serait vraiment très LR et pas du tout
Macron compatible et donc ces deux
candidates se sont présentés l'une
contre l'autre pour la majorité
présidentielle les deux ont pris
l'étiquette horizon les deux les deux
ont pris l'étiquette horizon le maire de
Reims a dû faire une conférence de
presse pour qu'il lui-même horizon pour
dire qu'il appelait ni pour lui ni pour
l'autre et l'histoire continue encore
mais je vais m'arrêter là mais quand
vous voyez aussi peu de dignité
finalement de la part de ces gens qui
jouent sur leur destin ou sur leur petit
calcul personnel et absolument pas sur
ce qu'il y a derrière une étiquette
politique pas non plus s'étonner que
derrière les Français en tirent la
conclusion c'est pas très intéressant de
se déplacer pour départager entre
Zébulon et bidulette
elle se sont reconnues
[Musique]
rejoindre les républicains rebonsoir
Jérémy les républicains qui se
réunissaient cet après-midi en comité
stratégique que s'est-il dit quand on le
rappelle les républicains ont terminé
quatrième de ce premier tour des
élections législatives avec
10,42% des voix loin derrière le
rassemblement national alors les LR
limitent la casse mais l'heure est
toujours à l'humilité en interne après
le très faible score obtenu à l'élection
présidentielle très peu de prise de
parole aujourd'hui au comité stratégique
où l'on a vu notamment François-Xavier
Bellamy Xavier Bertrand Gérard Larcher
et Valérie Pécresse premier enseignement
de ce conseil la consigne de vote pour
dimanche alors pas demain tendue
directement vers la coalition ensemble
mais le président DLR Christian Jacob
appelle ses électeurs à nouveauté ni
pour le RN ni pour la nuque dans les cas
où le parti est absent du scrutin on
l'écoute on voit bien que nous sommes
aujourd'hui le seul vote utile une
opposition
utile qui sera jamais dans les outrances
ni dans les excès mais qui sera
déterminé pour voter amender des
réformes qui pourraient aller dans le
bon sens et pour s'opposer durement à
celle qui auront à contresens de ce que
l'on de ce que l'on souhaite et de ce
qui est souhaitable pour le pays sur
notre position elle est conforme à la
ligne qui a toujours été celle de notre
une famille politique aucune voie sur la
ne doit se porter sur les extrêmes le
parti lierre qui se pose aussi en
arbitre de la nouvelle législature où il
est républicain compte bien peser au
Parlement dans les cinq prochaines
années même s'ils vont sans doute perdre
presque la moitié de leur députés ont
compté 101 député républicain élu en
2017 et on espère désormais au sein du
parti entre 55 et 65 députés élus
dimanche en cas de victoire d'ensemble
Christian Jacob assure que les députés
de la droite agiront pour réformer aux
côtés de la majorité présidentielle il
voteront lorsque les textes seront
constructifs selon lui et s'opposeront
si ce n'est pas le cas pour cela il
compte sur la majorité au Sénat bien
évidemment mais aussi sur les
amendements à l'Assemblée écouter le
des amendements des propositions et bien
après seront retenus où elles ne le
seront pas mais nous serons en situation
de faire bouger un certain nombre de
textes et notamment de réformer notre
pays ce qui aujourd'hui vaut sanctions
pour la République en marche c'est cette
politique de l'immobilisme et de vouloir
embrasser large à chaque fois et on voit
bien que nous avons une majorité
immobile pendant 5 ans et nous sommes en
situation de pouvoir faire bouger cela
est-ce qu'on sait sur quelle réforme le
partenaire souhaite intervenir à
Christian Jacob l'a évoqué en partie cet
après-midi et l'air souhaite intervenir
notamment sur les textes concernant le
pouvoir d'achat la sécurité
l'immigration mais aussi la santé mais
on imagine également que la réforme des
retraites prévues pour l'été 2023 sera
au centre des débats et des accords
entre la droite et la majorité
présidentielle si elles l'emporte
dimanche merci beaucoup Jérémy Mathieu
c'est quand même l'un des paradoxes de
ce de ce résultat quoi c'est à dire on
peut imaginer on va être prudent et on a
commencé ce débat en étant très prudent
sur les projections mais que LR voit son
nombre de députés quasiment divisé par
deux et pourtant ça va être un groupe
qui va peut-être peser mais c'est un
groupe qui va compter c'est un groupe
qui va compter si on ne la macronie n'a
pas de majorité absolue majorité
relative sinon pour le coup il ne compte
plus et d'accord ils seront éparpillés
de façon puzz mais sinon ils vont
compter évidemment parce que je le
disais tout à l'heure ils vont être
faiseur faiseur de loi c'est eux qui
vont donner leur accord on verra en gros
la majorité actuelle si jamais la
majorité relative va être contrainte
d'aller chercher des des députés à sa
gauche ou à sa droite à sa gauche c'est
très compliqué parce que la nuit pèse ne
fournira pas de de de de voix peut-être
selon un texte ou de symbolique mais on
les voit pas faire le jeu du
gouvernement on raille d'ailleurs
souvent la majorité Playmobil mais on
est aussi en France une opposition
Playmobil qui vote systématiquement non
à tout ce qu'on propose les autres vont
oui il y a tout à tout ce que le
gouvernement propose donc ça va être
compliqué lorsque 70% des textes
avec les frondeurs mais donc il peut il
peut aller chercher un petit peu à
gauche et dissident de gauche s'il y en
a des chaussures démocrates dont on
parlait tout à l'heure mais surtout la
majeure partie du Vivier elle se situe
évidemment à sa droite ce qui va le
déporter sur sa droite et ce qui va
colorer sa politique de machin
différente oui ça va de toute façon être
compliqué parce que prenons deux
hypothèses l'hypothèse majoritaire
absolue vous allez avoir déjà horizon et
le modem il est pas sûr qu'au Horizon
est le modem soit des partenaires de
coalition tout à fait calme de tant
qu'ils ont pas forcément été très très
contents et des investitures et des
nominations gouvernement être sur la
possibilité de rectifier le tirs
maintenant qu'un nouveau gouvernement va
être nommé un remaniement etc mais quand
même vous avez un Édouard Philippe et un
François Bayrou qui se verrait bien
calife à la place du calife par ailleurs
au sein de la majorité vous allez avoir
des députés la reine qui vont se dire
après Emmanuel Macron qui ne pourra pas
se représenter en 2027 moi je n'ai
aucune chance de repasser donc je suis
libre je fais ce que je veux vous n'avez
d'autres qui vont dire si je veux
repasser et si je veux avoir un nouveau
mandat il faut que je trouve un nouveau
cheval pour 2027 ça va très rapidement
créer des tensions au sein de la
majorité dans ce cadre avoir quelques
soutien LR peut être profitable si
évidemment vous n'avez pas de majorité
absolue là ça devient encore plus
complexe parce qu'en réalité on a
beaucoup le précédent Rocard et votre
petit reportage a bien introduit la
chose en disant que regarde c'est pas
reproductible c'est pas reproductible
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu'à
l'époque vous aviez des groupes qui
structurellement s'abstenaient les
communistes et les centristes et donc
quand il y avait une motion de censure
ces groupes-là ne la votaient pas donc
même si des textes pouvaient ne pas
passer et bien vous n'aviez pas de
motion censure qui pouvait passer or là
pour le coup et bien si elle est décidé
de voter une motion de censure bye bye
Elisabeth borne donc il faut au moins
que LR soit tenue de s'abstenir en cas
de notion de censure par ailleurs tenir
texte par texte peut-être mais Michel
Rocard avait un usage immodéré du 49
alinéa 3 depuis 2008 ce n'est plus
possible donc on rappelle la règle donc
il y a un 49 alinéa 3 par session plus
les projets de loi de finance à projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale grosso modo par an quoi alors
parents vous avez une session ordinaire
qui va qui court
1er octobre jusqu'au 30 juin et ensuite
vous pouvez jouer là dessus vous avez
des sessions extraordinaires et donc
pendant l'été vous pouvez faire passer
quelques textes supplémentaires grâce
aux sessions extraordinaires donc mais
ça vous fait pas évidemment un programme
de législature donc structurellement ce
serait un gouvernement qui serait dans
l'impossibilité d'appliquer son
programme sans avoir le soutien
structurel d'au moins quelques députés
de 6 là et donc de fait des facto un
accord en in ou un off avec LR serait
indispensable Jean Sébastien Ferjoux sur
ce je vous donne la parole s'apparer sur
ce destin paradoxal des lèvres qu'est-ce
que ça vous inspire
j'ai un peu en trompe l'oeil en réalité
parce que dans la pratique de Michel
Rocard au-delà des différences
institutionnelles il y avait aussi le
fait d'arriver avec un texte par exemple
en disant regardez on est là mais si
vous voulez si vous on vous donne ça
votez pour nous en réalité dès le départ
il voulait aller au sac quoi donc il y
avait une part d'entourloupe notamment
vis-à-vis du groupe centriste de
l'époque du groupe CDs de l'époque qui
on faisait des promesses en réalité
c'est ce qu'ils auraient voté ce qu'on
aurait proposé de toute façon mais
surtout j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans
une période où les parties sont plus
attentifs à l'opinion c'est-à-dire
regarder sur le covid les parties ils
ont pas réfléchi à quel était leur
posture à eux sur les libertés publiques
sur X ou x mesure de politique sanitaire
ils ont regardé ce que les Français ont
pensé dans les sondages avant d'en tirer
la conclusion de l'attitude qu'ils
adoptaient devant le Parlement et je
pense que ça serait un peu la même chose
c'est comme on est sur une politique
réduite au hashtag je sais pas quoi on
fait un signal justice enfin pouvoir
d'achat ou justice sociale ou sécurité
ou c'est un peu réduit à ça en réalité
et donc si c'est équilibre des finances
publiques bah oui les LR sont un peu
contraints d'aller dans ce sens là sauf
à ce qu'ils sentent qu'à ce moment là
les Français et les Français de droite
en particulier et dans un autre sens
parce que le vrai sujet va être celui
qui évoqué Benjamin Morel Emmanuel
Macron ne pourra pas se représenter
donc la question de la succession va se
poser très vite donc elle va se poser au
sein de ce qui serait sa propre majorité
comme elle va se poser au sein de ceux
qui auraient vocation à vouloir lui
succéder mais ils seront bien obligés de
se distinguer les uns des autres c'est
ces gens là donc le début du quinquennat
sera à mon avis assez différent de la
fin parce que là ils ont tous un théâtre
à essayer de marquer le plus leurs
différences par rapport aux autres et
alors ça va il y a quand même un cas de
figure et Mathieu l'a évoqué quand j'ai
posé la question c'est la possibilité
qui existe encore c'est que Emmanuel
Macron enfin ensemble obtiennent une une
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
on même si effectivement quand on prend
le bas des fourchettes des différents
instituts on voit que ça va peut-être
être difficile pour Emmanuel Macron d'y
arriver mais c'est encore une vraie
possibilité absolument c'est pas du tout
acquis contrairement à 2017 ou
effectivement entre les deux tours on
s'était dit bon là a priori il y aura
pas de problème là ça va être beaucoup
plus serré mais ce n'est pas exclu non
plus et juste pour revenir sur sur tout
à l'heure je pense que c'est un scénario
effectivement que la République
les républicains agissent deux concerts
de façon homogène et décide tous
ensemble de soutenir ou pas certains
textes mais ma crainte c'est qu'il y a
quand même plus de leadership vraiment
fort au sein des républicains et que ma
crainte est surtout qui se divise
pendant ce pendant exactement c'est 5
ans à venir et que on assiste à vraiment
la finalisation enfin là voilà là la fin
réelle de des républicains aujourd'hui
en France sans qu'ils arrivent vraiment
à agir comme un groupe homogène
en soutien ou contre la logique quand
même dans un régime où bien Parlement on
est dans un régime semi présidentiel en
France ça serait qu'il y ait des
négociations par exemple que les
républicains disent ok par exemple
nommer un garde des sceaux Corinne
politique pénale plus stricte que celle
mise en place pendant le premier
quinquennat et là vous avez notre
soutien ou alors engageons-nous sur un
programme sur quelques textes
fondamentaux mais le sujet c'est qu'on
ne sait même pas ce que veut faire
Emmanuel Macron
parce que dire on veut faire une réforme
des retraites ça veut dire tout est rien
une réforme des retraites mais c'est ça
probablement entre guillemets la plus
grande inflexion qui va être celle de
ces législatives c'est que la présidence
jupiterienne elle va être beaucoup plus
difficile à mener Jupiter arrive il
convoque la presse et il dit maintenant
le prix mais justement il va être obligé
de convoquer au moins les dieux d'Olympe
à chaque fois qu'il fait une proposition
c'est à dire qu'il va devoir demander à
Bayrou à Philippe si ce qu'il propose
peut-être peut passer au Parlement et
éventuellement les différentes
compositions composants de la majorité
éventuellement et je suis d'accord avec
vous il va falloir faire attention à
quelle va être la composition du groupe
LR si vous avez une composition qui
majoritairement tire du côté directionty
c'est pas la même chose que si vous avez
20 30 députés qui en fait sont plutôt
Macron compatibles si jamais il y a des
possibilités de faire des débauchages
individuels et que ensemble n'a besoin
pour combler ses effectifs que de 10 ou
20 députés ça peut marcher si en
revanche il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin si ensemble est dans une situation
profondément fragile en début de
quinquennat pour lier aux élections
parce des perditions la République en
marche a perdu beaucoup de députés entre
2017 et aujourd'hui à ce moment-là il
faut envisager un accord de coalition
plus large et évidemment faire un accord
avec Damien Abad c'est bien gentil faire
un accord avec Éric Ciotti c'est un peu
plus c'est un peu plus compliqué tout
est toujours un peu relatif quand on
voit des députés qui étaient parmi les
fers de lance de l'opposition Emmanuel
Macron chez les républicains constance
le gris par exemple ou Guillaume
l'arrivée qui sur les débuts du
quinquennat avait été très dur et
finalement ce sont retrouvés très Macron
compatible voire investi par la majorité
enfin la possible majorité macronienne
donc je suis d'accord avec vous sur oui
ça n'est pas la même chose si c'est
plutôt lalioti mais sur les individus on
a vu que tout était possible finalement
on va terminer là-dessus on s'était dit
qu'on allait parler d'Éric Zemmour c'est
symptomatique finalement on l'a pas fait
donc on se garde
peut-être ça pour pour mercredi Mathieu
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat